en las vacaciones pasadas visite la
tienda de mi tío y me sorprendí al
escuchar cantidades muy grandes como
tres mil 405 mil 867 mil 899 y es que
como sus clientes compran cajas y cajas
de mercancía tienen que pagar mucho
dinero recuerdo que me sorprendí cuando
le cobró a un cliente cinco mil 382
pesos y yo no sabía ni cuánto era así
que me explicó que para hacerlo más
fácil diera cada número por separado el
5 era de 5 mil y en billetes eran cinco
de mil por eso cinco mil el tres era de
300 y representaba tres billetes de 100
el 8 era de 80 y eran 8 monedas de 10
el último indica las monedas de un peso
y como es 2 en este caso serían dos
monedas de 1 vamos a practicar con este
número dos mil 794 puedes imaginar
cuántos billetes y monedas suman esta
cantidad recordemos la relación de los
números con los billetes y monedas serán
dos billetes de mil porque dos de mil
son dos mil
7 de 100 para tener 700 con las monedas
serían 9 de 10 es decir 90 y para
terminar serían 4 monedas de un peso
ahora debes saber que cada una de las
posiciones de los números tiene un
nombre de derecha a izquierda son
unidades después decenas
centenas y unidades de millar que son
los miles ves que es justo como
acomodamos los números para las monedas
de 110 y los billetes de 100 y 1000
esta forma de acomodar los números es
muy fácil es como partir los números
grandes en números redondeados y más
fáciles de manejar el primer número se
puede separar como con los billetes
cinco billetes de mil son cinco mil tres
de cien son 308 de diez son ochenta y
dos de uno son dos si sumo todos
tengo el 5.382 del principio para el
segundo número tenemos dos mil 794 que
sumados son dos mil 794 es como si
pusiéramos los números en escaleritas y
luego llenar amos los espacios con ceros
visto así es más fácil saber cuántos
billetes y monedas forman una cantidad
grande que llegue a los miles la próxima
vez que la ayuda metió en la tienda ya
no me asustara en los números grandes es
más hasta podría ayudarle